hello everyone since we started the day
with a nice win with the black pieces by
Rashid measurement you know I thought
we'd continue in the same style at this
game here it was played in the year 2000
in Buenos Aires Argentina
the game was suggested to me by my
brother-in-law yes the one that played
against Garry Kasparov I will put his
Lee chess link in the description below
so if you want you can challenge him for
some games but this game here it's
absolutely spectacular it's I mean if
you have if you don't know what to play
against efore play this so the game is
played between Pablo's definite scheme
he's a grandmaster from Argentina and
he's playing against Fabian Fiorito
international master of also from
Argentina and Popovich is a very strong
grandmaster he won the World Junior
Chess Championship in 1992 won his
Grandmaster title in 1994 and he
represented Argentina in the Chess
Olympiad five times so so a very strong
player let's see this game Paulo
sieminski has the white pieces and he
plays efore we have d5 the Scandinavian
defence he captures on d5 and now Knight
Knight to f6 not recapturing with the
Queen on d5 so this is a modern way to
treat this opening c4 and now we have
East six the Icelandic gambit D captures
on e6 and Bishop captures on e6 so
basically sacrificing a pawn for rapid
development d4 Bishop to b4 Czech Bishop
to d2 blocking the Queen to e7 now
Bishop captures Queen captures would
check Queen d2 offering a trade of
Queens but of course you don't
gambit upon to trade Queen so Queen back
to e7 and now threatening some nasty
discoveries with Bishop g4 for example
and black plays Queen to e3 and this is
I mean you have to block this discovery
somehow Bishop to e2 isn't really great
because Bishop captures in c4
you still can't recapture so black play
the gambit and he just recaptured his
pawn back so everything is fine for
black here so after Queen to e7 Queen to
e3 was played although Queen to e2 might
have been a bit better but then again
your
walking the development of your own
pieces so it's it's not clear at night
to see six by Fiorito and we have Knight
to f3 and this Knight to f3 moved was
actually the start of a disaster for
white in this position white wants to
play Bishop to e2 nice to f3 and Castle
and it's I mean these are the two moves
you want to play in the next two moves
but it's not the same in what order you
play them if you play Knight to f3 first
which was played in the game you'll see
what happens
Bishop to e2 was was a better move and
it allows white to continue the game now
Bishop is guarding g4 Knight to g4 isn't
really a serious threat now but in the
game Knight to f3 was played and Fiorito
immediately jumps in with Knight to g4
attacking the Queen Queen to e2 and we
have queenside castle and now white
doesn't really have a way to castle or
get his King to safety
so h3 now kicking the night away and
here if black would retreat with the
knight then white would have plenty of
time to finish his development but there
is one move that totally wrecks white
and and that's exactly what theater
plays he plays rook H to e8 completely
ignoring that this night can be captured
and here done it he captures the knight
H captures on g4 probably a developing
move like Knight c3 is better but again
you're getting you're getting into into
a bad position whatever you play so
might as well grab a piece H captures on
g4 and here comes Queen to b4 check and
you can't really block this if you play
Knight f2 d2 either Bishop captures on
c4 or g4 opens up a discovered attack
from the roof to the Queen you lose the
Queen and the game same thing if you
block with this Knight again
Bishop captures c4 same thing you lose
the Queen and the game so after Queen
before check Queen to d2 was played and
here comes the magic Bishop to g4 now
opening I discovered a check from the
rock on e8 Bishop to e2 blocking and now
rook captures on e2
with check the queen of course can
capture the queen is pinned so king
captures on e2 and now comes Knight
captures on d4 with check again you
can't move the Queen the knight can
capture it's also pinned so King to f1
and now comes Queen to c4 check if you
play King to e1 here then Bishop
captures on f3 and white is white is
simply destroyed
none of his pieces are developed and
he's getting checkmated you can't
recapture the bishop or Knight captures
on f3 this will fork your king and queen
so after this Quintus e4 check kink the
g1 was played and now here it comes
Knight captures on f3 would check the
King has nowhere to go the Knight has to
be captured G captures on f3 and here we
have Bishop captures on f3 you might
think why not grab the Queen well if you
grab the Queen then knife capture some
d2 would put a temple on the black Queen
Queen to e to F captures Queen captures
and now you're still better here and
probably you're gonna win this game but
again it's Queen against two rooks so
you'll have to work for a meal
so after G captures on f3 now Bishop
captures on f3 with the terrible threat
of queen g4 check trying something rook
to h3 was played here but you don't
really have a way of saving your Queen
not nor is that needs to be trying to do
wherever you play a queen g4 is coming
so rock to h3 preparing to meet Queen g4
we drove to g3
but it doesn't help Queen to g4 check
rub the g3 blocking and now Queen to h5
threatening Queen to h1 checkmate
so rook captures on f3 only move that
prolongs it and now again not capturing
the Queen with the rook but simply Queen
captures on f3 and in this position
Argentinian Grandmaster bubbles and
Itsuki resign the game it doesn't matter
what you play you're either losing the
Queen as white or you're getting
checkmated and I mean you can you can
give up
the Queen for the rook or simply you
can't even develop but but let's say you
play something like Queen to e3 you get
Ruby 1 check King H 2 to H 1 checkmate
and other than that there's really isn't
a move you can play black will simply
pick up the Queen and the Queen will
beat Knight and rook very easily so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and like I said if any of you don't know
what to play against e4 do try the
Icelandic gambit and if you are an
excellent in gambit player do share your
success in the comments so yeah I would
like to thank my brother-in-law for
suggesting me this game as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon